bonsoir pour la merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france tout d'abord
pour bien qu'on comprenne qu'elle est la
situation sanitaire actuellement en
israël
il y as jusqu'à dix mille nouveaux cas
par jour à la cofac 19 dans les chiffres
augmentent depuis juillet
1300 personnes sont en ce moment
hospitalisé la moitié d'entre eux
sont des cas graves
c'était 30 personnes sont mortes à ce
jour des lacs où vivent
70 pays dont il s'agit d'un repli de 9,3
millions d'habitants ce sont deux d'auge
tu vas que sa majorité faiza
la troisième campagne de vaccination est
traîné cela a commencé avec les
personnes de plus de 60 ans il pouvait
recevoir une troisième construction
rappelle
ce rappel est disponible à toute la
population
on évoque également effectivement un
quatrième rappel vous mettrais bien de
nous lire troisième dose en cours on
évoque un quatrième une quatrième dose
comment réagissent les isréliens ce
qu'ils acceptent la situation près une
troisième dose une quatrième est ce que
c'est envisageable
[Applaudissements]
pour faire
l'injection
touvre et à tous déployés à la fin de
l'année 2001 de plus la majorité des
israéliens semblent soutenir cette
campagne de vaccination
une personne sur cinq cependant être
contre la vaccination
cela n'a pas toujours été le cas mais au
fur et à mesure de plus en plus de
personnes ont remise en question jusqu'à
citer avec la campagne de vaccination
est le coordinateur que la réaction face
à la continuer mieux serait elle
explique avec avec l'apparition de
nouveaux variants il y aura de nouvelles
vagues il faudra donc y avoir de
nouveaux vaccins
on parle donc d'une nouvelle entité qui
correspondra à des rappels tous les six
mois où chaque année la plupart des
israéliens acceptent cette situation
beaucoup d'israéliens sont également
préoccupés par la hausse des cas c'est
un taux de contamination est très élevé
à l'échelle d'israël donc la plupart
d'entre eux soutiennent je tends pas les
vaccinations
mais certaines personnes se demandent si
la vaccination fonctionne vraiment s'il
ya encore tant de contaminer
effectivement votre pays a toujours
servi de laboratoire en quelque sorte
pour ce vaccin vous le dit très bien
aujourd'hui des doutes en tout cas des
voix qui doutent de l'efficacité de ce
vaccin ce que la polémique s'arrête là
où il ya vraiment de gros réfractaires
comme ici en france où notamment il ya
des manifestations on le voit antipas
sanitaire par exemple est-ce que la
contestation est forte aussi dans l'état
hébreu
[Applaudissements]
oui
j'avais pas la même chose en israël par
rapport à la france il n'y a pas de
manifestations de masse contre il est
bas
nous n'avons pas de telles
démonstrations de colère
sans doute également comme de france une
question politique en israël nous avons
un nouveau gouvernement un nouveau
premier ministre naftali bennett il
s'est montré très critique qu'il
faudrait du premier ministre précédent
benzouia tellement il s'agit sans doute
le confident afin de palier mc obindé
c'est pour cela qu'à ce jour il n'y a
pas eu doux et viveca finance depuis la
passation de pouvoir les gens sont très
inquiets avec des algues ont filmé en
israël la plupart sont opposés au
confinement et à ses effets sur les
côtes
est des personnes pourront entrer dans
les plis pour la première fois depuis 18
mois des plongées pour mieux pénétrer en
israël ils devront avoir assuré que
vaccins et devront pouvoir présenter des
certificats ou alors un certificat de
tests de moins de 24 heures puis à leur
arrivée dans le pays ils devront
effectuer des tests anticor
donc c'est un début de programme et
maquillés commencera le 19 septembre et
qui pourrait évoluer ce sera la première
fois en 18 mois jusqu'à 12 étrangers
pour entrer sur le territoire israélien
la majorité de la population ça reçu de
vaccin de pfizer mais cela ne serait
efficace pour mr koffi tca se sont que
9% c'est un peu plus bas que bree
chiffres disponibles il ya quelques mois
et fahrer lui-même réfute
statistiques
d'israël il ya effectivement qui va
grandissant mais la majorité du pays
soutient encore la vaccination qui pour
eux est le moyen de sortir de cette
situation actuelle avec la cofidis 9
merci beaucoup place l'aï remercié
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france